bonsoir rocco contento merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france il y aurait donc plus
de délinquance dans certains quartiers
du nord-est de la capitale
sauf que parier relativement calme avec
le wii le confinement mais il ya quand
même des quartiers où la délinquance
demeure il faut savoir que les quartiers
donc parle madame le maire de paris sont
essentiellement les quartiers nord de
paris à savoir 18e 19e et 20e
arrondissements de paris
ce sont les zones de sécurité
prioritaires et ce sont les secteurs les
plus criminogènes de paris la présence
policière est active elle est là
simplement qu' il faut que la gare de
périgueux le sache
non elle devrait le savoir c'est que
pendant le confinement et l'épidémie
coville 19
il faut savoir que les services de
police travaille en mode dégradé
donc vous avez 50 % des agents qui sont
à la maison en réserve opérationnelle
pour éviter que nous soyons nous mêmes
des vecteurs de la pandémie
donc effectivement pendant cette période
compliquée il ya moins d'agents sur le
terrain nous faisons face tout de même
il faut savoir que nous avons la mission
supplémentaire de vérifier que les
citoyens sont bien qu'on finit en
justement regardant toutes les
attestations ça nous prend beaucoup de
temps et il faut aussi parallèlement
lutter contre la petite et moyenne
délinquance
nous avons une ressource qui n'est pas
des plus fiables et effectivement
pendant ces périodes là c'est assez
compliqué pour nous de faire tout ce
travail et de tout cumulé prix d'autant
que on l'a vu dans certains quartiers la
haye la police continue d'être agressés
par par certaines personnes ce problème
de délinquance et il en réelle
augmentation ou alors perdure team
finalement dans ces mêmes quartiers qui
était problématique auparavant non c'est
un problème qui perdure ya pas de
l'augmentation exponentielle ce sont des
caries quartiers sensibles notamment
notoirement connu pour les trafics de
cigarettes et trafic de drogue de
cannabis drogue en tout genre et voilà
donc les policiers sont présents font
leur travail
il est vrai que nous n'avons pas une
ressource inépuisable ministre est
heureux d'avoir des policiers
supplémentaires pour faire continuer à
faire ses patrouilles et ce travail
néanmoins pendant cette période là c'est
compliqué parce que je vous le dis 50%
des policiers sont confinés à domicile
vous avez des collègues beaucoup de
collègues qui ont
qui sont suspectés d'avoir le coup de 19
qui ne sont pas testés et qui sont aussi
mis en 14 nm domicile et puis voilà il
faut dire aussi que le maire de paris
c'est une femme politique c'est pas la
première fois qu'ils aient de la ce
genre d'argument envers le préfet mise à
l'intérieur puisqu'il nous a pas échappé
que elle elle veut absolument mettre en
place sa police municipale à paris qui
devait être effective en janvier mais
qui avait été retoqué par l'assemblée
nationale donc aussi le le fait de faire
des sorties comme ça pour elle sa
légitime la mise en place de sa police
municipale à paris alors il ya une
certaine délinquance qui augmente
néanmoins ce sont les infractions
routières ça c'est un fait
oui alors les actes ce qui augmente le
plus je vais vous dire ce sont en ce
moment les différends familiaux il ya
beaucoup d'appels police secours pour
des différends familiaux donc voilà je
suppose que ça peut avoir un lien avec
le confinement et voilà le problème
c'est que sur le territoire national
vous avez beaucoup d'agents qui sont
réserve opérationnelle et la police
nationale travaillent je vous le répète
en mode dégradé jusqu'à la fin du
confinement
je pense que le 11 mai ça sera différent
et nous aurons tous les agents sur le
terrain
alors de quelle façon vous travaillez en
particulier puisque tout le monde n'a
pas de masque vous espère en avoir pour
le 11 mais j'imagine comment est-ce
qu'on travaille quand on est policier
justement pour intervenir dans certaines
situations compliquées où on est obligé
de se rapprocher les gens à nous très
clairement notre syndicat nous avons
majoritaire sur le tiers de femmes soit
nous avons donné la consigne à nos
collègues de ne pas intervenir s'ils ne
sont pas dotées de masques faut savoir
que le ministre de l'intérieur a promis
des millions de baths qu il y en a qui
commencent à arriver la pontiac de
police nous mais le syndicat nous avons
pas lié aux intérêts si du ministre
l'intérieur puisque pas plus tard que
vendredi donc hier nous avons été
demandé 50 mille masques au conseil
régional d'ile-de-france qui me les a
aimablement offert bon pour les offrir à
nous à tous nos agents
mais voilà le collègue n'intervient pas
ne contrôle pas s'il n'est pas dotées de
masques
il ne faut pas que nous soyons nous
mêmes des vecteurs de la pandémie kobe
19 et que nous leur apportions aussi à
nos familles lorsque nous rentrons le
soir dernière
si on recompte un taux est ce qu'il y
ait davantage de cambriolages ou de vol
dans les domiciles parisiens notamment
puisque ils sont fermés et certaines
personnes sont parties on sait alors je
n'ai pas d'éléments statistiques là
dessus ce qui est très clair les
éléments que nous avons c'est que il ya
beaucoup plus de vols à la roulotte ce
qu'on appelle à la roulotte c'est à dire
que les véhicules en stationnement qui
sont dégradées parce que effectivement
beaucoup de parisiens notamment
n'utilise plus ou très peu leur véhicule
quant aux cambriolages pour l'instant je
n'ai pas d'éléments statistiques à ce
sujet merci beaucoup
quand on comprend que d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur rtl france c'est merci
bien